Well,
America is,
has a wonderfully rich artistic legacy.
Uh,
it's predominantly European,
uh,
even though it's unfashionable to say
that,
but it's a,
a mix of European cultures that doesn't
happen in Europe.
And then by the time they got to the
west coast,
they were suddenly being hit with,
with native American,
uh,
with Asian,
with Latin American and oceanic
traditions too.
And so the American arts are in a funny
way,
a meeting place,
uh,
of world culture onto which are the kind
of a European DNA.
Everything else has been grafted.
Perfect example of this is jazz,
you know,
which takes this s four square European,
uh,
kind of music and then begins to
syncopate it to African poly rhythms.
And you know,
this,
uh,
you know,
and if you look at the way that the AF,
the African arts largely as they came
through the Caribbean and through
American slave culture,
completely transformed with the American
European arts are,
you know,
I think that what we are here as a
meeting place,
a kind of laboratory of,
of,
of human existence.
I mean,
there's a really interesting thing,
and I've really never heard anybody say
this.
If you look at the last hundred years of
the arts,
there has never been a place it,
all of human history that has had as
much happen as the United States has
during the last hundred years.
And it's ranged from classical music to
jazz,
to rock and roll to hip hop,
from abstract expressionist painting to
film,
to comic books.
Um,
you know,
to a newspaper,
uh,
you know,
cartooning,
uh,
novels,
poetry,
drama,
TV,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
I haven't even begun to exhaust the
arts.
I mean,
just in music loud.
And I do believe that in some funny way,
this unbelievable diversity of
expression has come out of the fact that
we were the first big society in
history,
uh,
which let the individual be free to
pursue with the individual wanted.
And that's why it's good not to have a
cultural policy.
The people should create their own art
in that ways that they want to do it.
And so,
uh,
I'm a huge fan of American art,
even though I have often criticize
aspects of American culture.
There's something happening in American
culture.
It's never happened before in all of
human history,
and it's exciting.